now we begin with the protection racket
that's the focus of tonight's angle
for almost a year now democrats have
controlled the white house in both
branches of congress their left-wing
allies dominate our universities our
public and private schools our newsrooms
the entertainment industry
and even many mainline churches
so why do they seem so miserable
they've gone from trying to scare you
about the latest covet variant to
railing on about how democracy is in
peril insisting that the only solution
is legislation that shrinks state
authority over their own elections
and of course they've been obsessing
over january 6th
today they went all in
we are
in a battle for the soul of america
december 7th 1941
september 11th
2001
and january 6
2021 know that as we reflect on that
darkest day we remember that the
insurrection sought not only to attack
the building
but to undermine democracy itself i
viscerally feel the pounding on the
gallery doors truth is clear as this
shard of broken glass
that i have carried
with me
for the last 365 days
now this was the theater of the
political absurd none of these democrats
who spoke today
really believe our government faces an
ongoing threat from magamobs
if they were truly worried about
political violence which we condemn no
matter who perpetrates it
they would have been on their high
horses condemning it in the summer of
2020 as well
now i was there in lafayette park across
from the white house
when fires were starting
bricks were being unloaded from
backpacks
police barricades were being pushed up
against
all manner of things would be being said
to the capitol police and the police
surrounding the white house
i was sickened when violent force was
used against the capitol police on
january 6
and i was sickened by what i saw that
night in lafayette park as well
now in objective terms the damage caused
by the 2020 floyd riots was far worse
than what happened on january 6th
they were the costliest civil unrest
riots in the u.s history with insured
losses estimated at over 2 billion
dollars
so by the end of that summer of love
more than 2 000 law enforcement officers
were injured and 574 riots were declared
during those riots 624 arsons were
reported 97 police vehicles were burned
officers were pelted with bricks water
bottles fireworks and even molotov
cocktails
according to the washington post 25
people died across the country as a
result of those riots
yet almost all of the democrats emotion
their real emotion was reserved for
george floyd and his family and the
protesters themselves
they were courageous demonstrations
infiltrated by perhaps a few bad apples
when protesters ascended on washington
during the kavanaugh hearings they
smeared him and his family they cornered
senators and elevators and of course we
remember how they banged on the doors of
the supreme court
democrats didn't opine about protecting
the integrity of the process or the
institution
they loved every minute of it
so allow me to decode what really
happened on the hill today and into the
night
all of the emoting and hyperbole was
really the last gasp of the old guard
the dinosaurs of the pelosi schumer age
are about to go extinct
they know their political con game is
coming to an end in november
and they're so petrified that trump or
someone with similar views will win the
presidency in 2024
that they're even willing to team up
with an old nemesis
what was actually going on with these
so-called enhanced uh interrogation
techniques that torture the attitude
that was there
was very
i think
came from dick cheney handing out
billions of dollars in contracts without
a bid to halliburton while you're still
on the payroll makes you unfit to lead
this country you can always tell when
the republicans are restless
because the vice president's motorcade
pulls
into the capitol
and darth vader emerges
but there darth was on capitol hill
today dick cheney representing the
mastodons of the bush age
decrying what's happened to his old
party
republican leadership handling of this
of the reaction to january 6. it's not a
leadership
that resembles any of the folks i knew
when i was here
now first let me say i've always liked
dick cheney personally and i defended
him when nancy pelosi and others trashed
him
but the condition he and george w left
the party and in 2008 was this
they had lost the house the senate and
of course then the presidency
in may of 2008 george w bush was the
most unpopular president in modern
history with a 71 disapproval rating
that's worse than biden's
and by december of that year chaney
himself was earning similar accolades in
the veep category
so all the latter day reinvention won't
change the fact that the bush cheney
policies prove thoroughly unpopular some
of them i actually support it
but economic collapse endless wars
in january 2009 w's approval rating
stood at 22
and dick cheney comes to capitol hill to
decry the direction of the party
a republican party that has grown more
diverse bigger and more blue-collar
since cheney left washington
now that's funny
the fact is the bipartisan regime that
kept the wars going on long after
americans really wanted to be there
they really care more about promoting
democracy abroad than preserving it at
home
they're the ones who don't really trust
democracy
because they know that when the people
get their way it means things like
border enforcement ending unlimited
immigration
keeping politics out of schools and
protecting women's sports
they simply can't risk another repeat of
2016.
it sounds like congresswoman that the
goal of the committee perhaps is to go
after trump's inner circle and prevent
the former president from running for
president again
is that a fair assessment of the goal no
the goal of the committee is what i said
we need to know
what members of this body
were doing what they were engaged in
no please now today was just another act
and their dramatic effort to save their
dying species
yet none of it's going to distract from
their own failures on inflation covid
the border these wars afghanistan
and the gop is never ever going back to
the bush cheney playbook no thank you
to preserve democracy you actually have
to trust your people but they don't
and they're ruthless
you refuse to concede that america is
systemically racist
you're labeled a racist
if you show up to complain at school
board meetings you're a domestic
terrorist
if you share your conservative opinions
online
you get cancelled
and if you simply attended a rally in
washington on january 6
you're an insurrectionist
how weak these cheney democrats have
proven themselves to be
they control all levers of power in
america
and yet their message to the world is we
can't govern and our democracy is about
to collapse
once again china has to be laughing
they're doing its work
what a wild thing to see in just 12
years democrats have gone from hope and
change to doom and gloom
pelosi's propagandistic production on
capitol hill was a blatant and cheap
attempt to deflect attention from the
cascade of calamities piling up under
her democrat majority
but none of it's working
in just under 10 months the voters of
america will end her protection racket
for good and that's the angle hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else